but this hbo special is really the first
thing that i've watched
you know when i was editing it i've
never watched it after i edited it but
where i watch it i'm like yeah these
bits are completed
like they're completed i i and that's
something i have to thank fringe for
i i went all the way through the bit and
when you go
all the way through it and it's like i a
great book that people should read
if comedians should read uh that
helps with comedy i think and i'm i'm
about to reread it is
uh how to win an argument by cicero it's
this book that i found
uh you know in a bookstore being a
pretentious dickwad but i found this
book and i was like
oh this is he was a lawyer who had to
not only represent his friends but his
enemies and he's like one of the
greatest
arguers i don't even know if there's a
word but he's like one of the greatest
talkers of all time and
he lays it out it's a very short read
but it's it's something that
in it something in it uh really i read
it before i did fringe and
it made me i kept thinking about this
during the french festival which was
like
when you have an idea cast a
very wide net so that when you pull it
back
you've gone through everything so when
you have an idea
like cast the widest net possible to see
what you can catch in it
and then when you pull it all back in
you'll have
you'll know you went everywhere with the
idea
so where you settle will be the best
idea i i think he says it better than
that and the idea might be a little
different but
point being is like with a premise i
want to start working on like
i always loved watching guys like kurt
metzger because
kurt metzger was a guy where i'm like
man
that angle on that joke is
unique and perfect in a way that
no one else is going to do that angle
nate napar gets he's
unbelievable at that napar gets he's
unbelievable at finding those and things
that are just as simple as like
great jelly you know if i say like grape
jet like
i've had several conversations on the
phone with nate
where in conversation he said something
whether it be about buying a tiger or
whether it being about having ketchup in
your refrigerator at the time it was
grape jelly
and he changed it to ketchup but then
i'll watch his stand up
and be like my god he's got four
different angles on that
that maybe we didn't have in the
conversation but that he's built into
this
that are just genius it's just so funny
and i really love that about all my
friends you know a guy like vekione
who can do a mega bus bit where if i
told you there's a mega bus bit you'd be
like i don't know if i could listen to
15 minutes of that
but then you see veki owns and it's
layered and it's nuanced and it's really
funny
and i always i always really love those
kind of jokes